Daniel I wanted to ask you something
maybe that's a little sensitive for
Bobby but um
why do you get so nervous everybody he
seems to think he's been intentionally
left out of the stop Asian hate movement
I've heard this I've heard this
he wants to do a PSA and I just want to
see like yeah I want to hear your
thoughts on if you think he was left out
intentionally and if you think he's not
a good face for the campaign you know
what I'm saying to shave and lose
that's it yes Bobby it's been a whole
conspiracy of these two no that's not
what I'm saying what I was saying
earlier was you know in the past was is
that I just don't feel like people would
believe me
like even if I was saying like I
remember one time will I am yeah Will I
Am goes come over because I'm doing this
you know I don't know what the [__]
cause was and I had to lift up cards
like you know how Bob Dylan did in the
thing right and I saw the final thing
and the I was the only one they cut out
and I remember doing the cards and when
I want to just be like it just doesn't
feel like you care wait do you even
remember what the campaign was I don't
even remember that's why
it was a minorities or something did you
care did you care at the time I was like
trying to cry well that's and I was and
I was doing that they're like what are
you doing I'm feeling it you know what I
mean that was your intention to cry well
it was a thing he was like you know all
these people are doing I think Morgan
Freeman's do all these people and they
go it's a real personal thing I know
you're a comedian but it's real so give
me the cards man you want to see real
and after I was done they were like yeah
okay okay thank you and it just they
just cut me out what's your card did
they have writing on it yeah and like
stop you're just racism now how did it
dramatically work if they cut you out in
the middle of a sentence
he had a blank card was yours like the
period or something
no I
well I think what it was
30 people yeah and they cut this thing
together into one thing right and they
just I didn't even get a card or a
period or nothing I was not in it and in
my head I'm like oh I'm not you know I
mean
yeah I
I'm just I'm not disappointing my thing
people are different time though for you
because now I mean you're crying a lot I
know what I'm saying is that if there's
a cause for Asians they're not going to
call me is what I'm saying but there is
no bat phone you know there's no like
signal that goes out to say calling all
agents who care about it
oh there's no
did you do stop Asian hate stuff yeah I
did okay I know you did right so if
there was no bad phone how'd you get in
on them because I just started talking
about it and that's the thing no one you
don't need permission Bobby like if
people if you start talking about this
and it becomes important do you
like-minded people are going to find you
and then they're going to be like I
heard Bobby talking about this on his
podcast let's have him be a part of this
because I know he feels this so yeah we
talked about it it's organic but you
know but not a good way I don't think
yeah yeah I think I think my point of
view was different
um there's a part of me that thinks that
it's just human nature that you don't
mean violence is human nature and this
and that but
there's also a part of me that thinks
that human beings can evolve and change
and
um it doesn't need to be a part of our
that's the thing right that's the hope
that's what people like Martin Luther
King were were talking about their
entire lives like evolving to a place
where we don't let our baser nature win
that's what we have to appeal to that's
who we need to talk to because you have
to believe that there's a segment of the
population who wants the same thing and
if we can convince more of them to to
move us forward
then then we'll be making progress
because we can't expect that everyone is
going to agree with us there's gonna let
me look at climate change and look at
all the other issues facing our country
that are existential our world that are
existential yeah we can't make movement
on it yeah so just goes to show you how
powerful the forces on both sides are
yeah but it's really
companies and CEOs and stuff I mean that
you know I mean when you when they
they're when we have lobbyists like that
and we have them running the [__]
show
they're not gonna you know deregulate
they're not gonna they want to make
their [__] money man right and so
then they they go to a certain segment
of people and they lie to them and this
is where we are yeah